it's official Chicago has lost its mind
the windy city electing far left
Democrat Brandon Johnson as mayor
instead of the police union-backed
candidate Paul Ballas Johnson is
supported by Bernie Sanders and is in
the pocket of the powerful teachers
union he ran on a plan to defund the
Chicago Police and raise the city's
taxes and now Johnson thinks his win
will embolden progressives Nationwide
this game
[Music]
this can be better stronger safer
Chicago for all the people of Chicago
let's take this bold Progressive
Movement around these United States of
America Chicago we can show the country
we can show the world what's possible
when we stand on our values as one
people
it couldn't come at a more dangerous
time there were four Chicago shootings
on election day yesterday and total
crime is up a whopping 46 percent so far
this year his plan to take on Chicago's
crime crisis fund more social workers
instead of cops no wonder Newsweek
called him the police's worst nightmare
and it sounds like Brandon wants to go
to war with the police Union
we tend to limit our conversations
around toughness in more police officers
and what has been proven over and over
again that is not a recipe for absolute
success with the Fraternal Order of
Police leader
um has said that doesn't necessarily
reflect the values of the city of
Chicago police officers are showing up
to 9-1-1 calls responding to domestic
challenges that quite frankly should
have a mental health support
um person there that that leads that
interaction
you know I have to say this before I ask
the question he just said responding to
domestic challenges a domestic violence
call is the second most dangerous call a
police officer can respond to and he
wants to send a social worker so from
there I'll go to uh yeah I'll go
and ask you I mean why would Johnson
make defunding the police Brian a
priority in a city that is overwhelmed
with crime and so many people have
backed off that statement over the last
two years uh outside one in uh
congresswoman uh congresswoman Bush over
in Missouri but he was called the union
quoted saying this if we do not get Paul
valus elected there will be a major
Exodus from that group who will not work
for uh a bigger anti-police mayor than
the current one and that's what he is
this is um every you know the only thing
down is shootings and murders slightly
everything else is up in Chicago so
we're going to see now by the way has
anyone asked a healthcare worker if they
want to go to a domestic dispute you
pretty much go to oldest schooling to
sit in office and and charge everyone
way too much per hour now all of a
sudden it's like oh the officer called
we need you to go to uh the Avenue Q
because it's a domestic dispute I'm
pretty sure they don't want to be in the
back of a police car and we're going to
say we're going to see if this
experiment but now that he's got the
keys to the keys to the car we're going
to see how his thoughts about about
policing come to fruition my sense is
within six months he's going to have a
major turnaround oh there's no question
police are going to be leaving like
crazy right there's no you're gonna have
to change that approach yeah yeah all
right so Dana I'll go to you now 62
percent of Johnson's funding has come
from the teachers unions why are they
working so hard to keep a democrat in
office given this state of the inner
city schools let me just say Chicago
Public Schools got 2.8 billion dollars
they've spent 1.5 that's a little more
than half yeah I read somewhere today
somebody said the new boss in town is
the Chicago's teachers union yeah and so
okay fine I'm just trying to think does
does this new guy who won the election
does he deserve a period like a
honeymoon period a benefit of the doubt
and I want to say yes but my heart says
no and when you were talking about the
police officers if you are in one of
those growing cities in the South and
you need more police officers start
making those recruiting calls because
they're going to want to leave and
they'll leave before their pension is up
because they can get paid more and they
can actually do the jobs that they want
to do I want to point out something else
though Republicans yesterday lost the
Wisconsin Supreme Court race as well
there was something very interesting
that happened in Chicago that's
connected with Wisconsin in my mind well
two things actually
this guy the new mayor Brandon Johnson
most of the ads that he did against Paul
Valles were about abortion because 10
years or so ago Paul vales said
something mildly supportive of a
pro-life position but then said but I
just want everybody to do their own
thing but for me personally I would be
pro-life so they tagged him as a
pro-life crazy nut and there was no
response on it and it has nothing to do
with the running of a city now go next
door to Wisconsin Republicans lose by 10
points now they won a lot of the
conservative ballot issues the issues
that are on the ballot but the candidate
on the Republican Supreme Court case he
lost by 10 points and Republicans used
to be able to count on their voters
turning out in the midterms the left has
really woken up to making sure that gen
Z gets out and vote if you look at the
vote and where it came from especially
in Wisconsin at the University of
Madison for example University of
Wisconsin and Madison it was staggering
the numbers are staggering and that is
going to happen all across the country
yeah I think so and you know we've seen
a shift Jesse in in recent days I mean
recent elections Democrats not just
reversing the defund police like mayor
Adams and and uh Jesse Chester Boudin
getting thrown out but Democrats and
house races
um what happened here
aren't they in enough pain in Chicago
well I'm formally withdrawing my support
for the city of Chicago if they want
insanity they can have it they voted for
this they deserve it I'm not going to
sit up here Jesse Waters is not going to
say oh this is what you need to do this
is what you need to do no I'm done
Barack Obama didn't even endorse a
candidate here
he's supposed to be the Chicago dream
kid and he set it out Warren comes in
Bernie comes in endorses the Kook the
Kook wins and barack's in Hawaii smoking
a cigarette what does that say to you
about Barack Obama and Chicago he
doesn't care it's a political machine in
that City
the Chicago Teachers Union is the muscle
they're the second largest teachers
union in the country and if you give the
union two weeks early voting to drum up
support for the Kook the kook's going to
win and it's not even close they can
Harvest they can do whatever they need
to do
and I'm sorry I am canceling my next
trip really and I'm not a boycott guy
unless you're getting a speech there
then yeah yeah you know Barack Obama has
a library in that City
we're going to talk about that
it's your segment it is yes okay Kim Fox
told people that she should support uh
Brandon Johnson and the crazy part of it
is everything is an illusion it's she's
a D.A and he is the guy who's going to
save everybody and every people are not
who they say they are and the people of
Chicago don't care I know Paul Valles
when he he went and turned the school
system around there and New Orleans and
I believe he spent some time in
Philadelphia he's one of the more
respected and big thinkers in the
Democratic party I thought he was going
to win this race Dana's point I think is
the point as you think about this
politically and you zoom out and you
think about national elections and other
Statewide elections abortion and I would
argue he ran ads showing that Paul
Ballas was was linked to Betsy DeVos and
and other that Trump supporters were
supporting uh uh Paul Valance Paul
Valance lost by 15 or 16 000 votes that
issue is going to be a serious one I
root for the city still I love this I
love the city of Chicago I have family
in Chicago my godson lives in Chicago my
best friend from high school lives there
I got I want to give this guy the
benefit of the doubt I hope he
understands that if he does not turn
around this crime issue if his ideas are
not don't seem to work and don't
resonate I hope he has the agility and
nimbled us to change because we have to
root for him because these kids we have
a Fox News contributor who lost a family
member there in Chicago who I've seen
speaking I've seen speaking very
eloquently over the last several hours
on the network he has a very strong
theory of the case for his sake and for
every kid's sake in Chicago I hope that
this mayor if his plans work we give him
Kudos and if they don't work I hope he
has the capacity and ability to say I
was wrong and here's what I got to do
differently you know what we can't wait
another year and more people being
killed carjacked and everything else
there's nothing that he talks about that
will be effective in fighting crime
period let's hope we're wrong I'm not
wrong on that hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hot honest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else